greetings miss dornick
my name is harry selden
i am a professor at streaming university
on trantor
hey guys pete here today we've got a
breakdown of foundation episode 5 upon
awakening takes us back in time and it's
the first episode where we don't see
anything involving the cleons we also
start to get answers about what happened
with gail and rach and watch as things
continue to develop on terminus i'm
going to recap everything we saw and
then i'll give you my thoughts on what
happened what i think it means going
forward and before we get into that i
just have to give you a spoiler warning
if you haven't watched episode 5 yet
then this video isn't for you with that
out of the way let's get into it
season 1 episode 5 opens with gail
telling us about the stories that scared
her the most as a child they were about
black holes it was the idea of an event
horizon venture into that and the
gravitational pull prevents you from
turning back escape becomes impossible
and you can see the parallel of what's
going on with her after she made the
decision to try to solve the abraxas
conjecture in flashback we go back to
see how that played out at one point
gail was involved with the seer church
she was an acolyte and this seems to be
a point of pride for her parents as her
community has turned to their faith in
light of this climate catastrophe that's
going on on their planet the sea level's
rising that's threatening their way of
life and we hear how it's getting more
and more difficult for her family to
make their living through the farming of
algae we already understood this from
the first episode so the main thing here
is this connection she has with an old
family friend who's been labeled as a
heretic she finds him one night after
going to the university which is
supposed to be abandoned he's there
looking through the books and when she
tells him that he needs to leave because
the seers have condemned the building he
says that the books are heretical right
that all analytical learning goes
against the faith of the awakening he
says the line here that we heard her say
to rach that when a planet wants you
dead you die she tries to get him to
leave without the books and he offers
her the writing from cali which is what
she'll end up using to solve the problem
that gets her to trantor the last thing
he tells her is the cleanse will pass
all things have a cycle the knowledge
helps to survive the destruction until
the rebirth arrives and you see gail try
to reframe his statements to fit the
church's ideas that the floods are a
challenge from the sleeper that they
just have to endure and then eventually
it'll all get better he counters that
people did this we did this not the
slumbering god so this guy is the
localized version of harry selden right
he sees this collapse is coming that
can't be stopped by putting your faith
into this church's system later we see
him being executed for being a heretic
as an acolyte gail is there she has to
help prepare him for the ceremony and
the books are submerged with him his
final statement is that this will not
stop the seas from rising and there's a
seed planted there so gail goes back
alone later she swims down and recovers
calais writing and even though she's
starting to rise up in the ranks of the
church she starts reading about math she
uses her new knowledge to solve the
abraxas conjecture and eventually she
enters the competition and gets the
message that she solved it and that
harry will validate her proof he tells
her that the empire will be reaching out
but that he hopes that she'll come to
strealing university on trantor to meet
him which of course we've already seen
her do that we get a little bit more of
her parents being pissed her father
tells her he'd rather his daughter die
than go to the machine world of trantor
but at this point knowing there's
nothing left on synax but destruction
she's past the point of no return and
decides to choose science over faith
hoping that she can find a way to save
her people through getting off the
planet and going to work with harry
selden
it cuts back to the present timeline and
we see her escape pod being brought
inside this ship where she wakes up she
remembers harry's death and notices that
she has rach's knife inside the pod that
comes in handy when she can't open the
door the knife is pulled into this slot
and is basically the key and as she goes
inside we realize that the ship's ai
thinks that she's rach as it's
initiating things for his arrival she
finds out she's alone there and that the
ship won't give her access to some
functions because again she's not race
she's not the person the ship was
expecting she finds out that she was
asleep for nearly 35 years so what's
happening here is happening at the same
time as what's going on with salvor and
the encyclopedist on terminus we see
them and it picks up right where they
left off salvor's looking at the large
weapon just outside the fence and the
fact that the enacrions are using a
cloaking device they're hiding it from
someone other than the people on
terminus confirms that their motive goes
beyond terminus itself and right at that
moment the imperial jump ship arrives
and now we know what's going on back at
terminus city you see that the
encyclopedists are thrilled that they
actually came that the empire is backing
them up but also that this is exactly
what farah was hoping would happen the
ship the aegis makes contact and
essentially learn that they don't have
any military they talk to salvore who's
the warden and she explains that they
confess to destroying the communications
buoy and so he wants to talk to pharaoh
directly to see what she has to say
about that salbore thinks this is a
mistake but her communications are
jammed before she can really say her
piece and then lewis goes to get pharah
and bring her into the tower this sets
off red flags with the troops
surrounding the fence salvor doesn't
want pharah to go anywhere near the
tower and so she races to the city there
she realizes she's too late lewis is
already taking pharah over to the tower
and there she pulls out a field
disrupter that she hid in her fake
eyeball and when she detonates that that
shuts down the fence the anacrion
warriors are then able to charge into
the city and you see that they are
killing some of the colonists the
imperial ship sees what's happening on
the ground and starts to land while
salvor is looking for pharah who has
taken her mother hostage when she finds
her there's an intense standoff where
salvo won't drop her gun to save her
mother and after that works out they
have a crazy one-on-one fight where
salver eventually gets the upper hand
but farrah's men are there they have her
mother again so it's essentially a
standoff later when they're looking over
the destruction pharah points out that
terminus isn't innocent she says that
selden's predictions are what inflamed
the empire in the first place because of
what their prophet said her whole world
burned and there is some truth to that i
guess from her perspective although
there is this ongoing mystery of who
actually blew up the star bridge the
fighting continues on the ground people
are definitely dying we see hugo get
shot and then as the imperial ship
approaches we see that the anacrions
were assembling that weapon in order to
take out the ship and we see it come
down to the ground so we see what their
larger plan was although it's not clear
to me what the motivation behind it is
we're gonna have to wait and see because
they're not actually in a position to be
able to fight back if a full-blown
battle breaks out with the empire it
feels like it has to be more specific to
that ship or this location but we don't
find out before the episode ends
back on the ship gail can't get
authorized to do anything important like
send a message or guide the ship
somewhere different she is able to do a
search of the imperial database though
and she learns that the slow ship did
make it determinus she looks into
harry's death she finds out the official
story is that he was murdered by rach
and she's listed as an accomplice and
per his own directive harry was ejected
in a casket he designed himself and we
do see his body being sent out into
space she searches for rach and finds
footage of him being questioned by the
encyclopedist lewis parent is now in
charge after harry's death rach admits
that he murdered harry and won't say
much about it other than implying that
he understands more about why things
happen the way they did than lewis does
for his crime he is executed and we see
him get space they throw him outside in
the vacuum without a suit before that
happens we see his final words he says i
know it's hard i know what i've done
seems incomprehensible but you can never
lose faith in the plan ever you can
still solve a puzzle even with a piece
missing and it almost feels like he's
talking directly to gail here knowing
that he put her on the escape pod in his
place of course she breaks down after
watching this and there's a point where
she briefly contemplates suicide she
brings a scalpel into the shower
thinking about her time with rach and
then before she can go through with it
the ship changes its course and that
flips her around it gives her a chance
to think and she decides to try to
figure out what's going on there's a
somewhat long sequence where she can't
find out where they're going the ship
won't tell her where they're going so
she uses the information she can get in
math to figure out what direction
they're going in then she can't see
outside because there's a view screen so
she goes and she finds a suit tethers
herself does a space walk she can't see
anything at first with the naked eye but
once she looks in infrared she realizes
they're heading towards a dark star with
that information gail realizes that
their destination is helicon harry's
homeworld which we don't have a lot of
background about in the show and as
she's figuring that out she starts to
see some strange things she sees what
looks like puddles of blood and then she
comes across a glitched out projection
of harry where he looks like he did the
last time she saw him and the episode
ends there this is probably related to
the device we saw rach remove from
behind his ear harry is dead but now
it's apparent there was more to his plan
that would happen after that event
this week had a lot of promising signs
about how they plan the story out i find
myself pretty invested in what's gonna
happen i think the show still has some
pacing issues and don't necessarily love
how they structured things jumping
around but we are getting answers to
questions they encouraged us to have and
we can see that they're pulling on
threads that were left dangling in the
early episodes finding out that rage
sacrificed himself to get gail out is an
interesting twist kind of sad to see him
go and the flashback to cinex does a
good job to define her character but
then also makes you wonder how that all
came to be considering that's what led
her to where she's at and then on top of
that she would have never seen harry's
death if she hadn't had a feeling about
that his return was a genuine shock
although i wish they hadn't put off the
reveal of what's going on there the way
things have been it may be a couple of
episodes before we get back to that but
it is still fun to think about how the
ship she's on plays a part in his plan i
guess we can say for sure that he
planned ahead and recruited rach to help
him with his death but it's hard to say
how gayle being there instead will
change things going forward hopefully
her seeing harry at the end of his life
is evidence that his whole consciousness
was downloaded and she'll be able to
interact with him rather than him just
being some welcoming hologram or
something like that a lot of this
episode is about motivations there's a
continuation of the idea of faith from
the last episode and we do see gail pick
science over that but more we see that
gayle's motivations are reinforced and
acrion's motivations against terminus
are starting to take shape and we know
what was behind rach killing harry the
ship gail finds herself on looks pretty
great the production is still over the
top and the shot of the aegis coming
down was amazing looking once again
terminus turns out to be less
interesting than the other story which
is disappointing since that is the
beginning of the actual foundation even
without trantor and the clones terminus
is still coming in second place but we
are only halfway there so there's still
plenty of time and i'm still interested
to see how things fall into place it's
kind of fun that at this point as a book
reader i'm not sure where we're going
from here i'm not sure what they mean
here when they say a dark star or why
rach would be headed to helicon i'm
guessing since they had that whole
sequence to show that gail couldn't see
it with her naked eye it has something
to do with its strange properties of
course i did look it up but couldn't
decide what they were going for here
based on the limited information they
gave us in the show and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you thought about
this episode and where you're hoping
they go from here if you want to talk
book spoilers i'm all for it just mark
those so you won't spoil things for show
only people please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon